let's say you want to start a vid Quine
company in the u.s. chances are you're
gonna need a money transmitter license
or rather 51 of them because 47 states
three territories in the District of
Columbia each have their own permitting
process for any business that handles
money on behalf of its customers
here's Megan Byrne the CEO of the
Bitcoin exchange firm coin X talking
about what this process has been like
for her company some applications have
been in for over a year and we're unable
to determine the path forward as it's
not a clear process fred aresome
co-founder of the bitcoin wallet firm
coinbase says that so far becoming
compliant in just half the states has
taken his company two years and costs
two million dollars but dealing with the
states is just the beginning
Bitcoin firms also have to abide by the
rules of the federal Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau and the US Treasurys
Financial Crimes enforcement Network
which just sent a chill through the
industry by finding the cryptocurrency
startup ripple labs $700,000 for
allegedly violating its rules
Jeri Britto is the executive director of
coin Center in industry advocacy group
it takes lawyers in each state it means
criminal background checks in each state
it means bonds for each site it's it's a
huge barrier of entry instead of sorting
out this regulatory amass government
officials are piling on even more red
tape Benjamin Loski New York state's top
financial regulator has spent the last
year hammering out the details of the
so-called bit license which will apply
to any company that serves customers in
New York right now the regulation of
virtual currency industry is still akin
to a virtual Wild West loss key points
to a slew of recent headlines about drug
sales alleged money laundering and theft
in the Bitcoin world but these
activities are already illegal under
existing laws and regulations and New
York already requires that companies
obtain a money transmitter license it's
duplicative it doesn't achieve any new
purpose to have to require two licenses
when you do the background check for one
license what's the point of doing a
background check for another license
while the final details won't be
released until later this month the most
recent draft of the bill
since his provisions that specifically
duplicate federal regulations that are
already on the books it has an anti
money laundering provision which is
something that's unprecedented anti
money laundering is something that the
federal government handles it's handled
by FinCEN Financial Crimes enforcement
network at the Treasury Department so
now if you are a business not only do
you have to file suspicious activity
reports and to know your customer for
the federal government now for the first
time you have to do it for a state as
well
bruce fenton is the executive director
of the Bitcoin foundation we already
have existing laws against fraud against
hacking so really what we are left with
is something very onerous and burdensome
for not just American companies but
companies all over the world instead of
stating you can't do business until you
meet every requirement that has yet to
be defined give us a probationary
licence so that we can get that process
moving forward ideally a small startup
to go to one place whatever that is and
have clear and simple rules that they
could follow to get that license we
don't know when the next Facebook is
gonna come along started by a guy in his
dorm what if he would have had to spend
four million dollars to start that we
would have never seen it we may not even
know what kind of innovations are around
the corner if we stifle that innovation
before it even has a chance to start